a Phoenix police officer's quick
response prevented what could have been
a school shooting it happened on
September 22nd at Mountain View School
in North Phoenix police released this
body camera footage showing a woman now
identified as 29 year old desira
features grabbing a weapon from her
purse while outside the school
the Phoenix Police Department released a
snippet of the body camera video from
the incident tweeting quote when it
comes to protecting your children there
is no time to waste when we see a threat
thanks to the heroic actions of this
Phoenix police officer a possible school
shooting was prevented a spokesperson
with the Phoenix Police Department tells
lawn crime Network a school resource
officer was on campus at the time of the
incident they were called to the front
office for a domestic dispute over a
child's custody that's when features the
mother of a student grabbed her weapon
investigators say features was then
arrested and booked into jail she's now
accused of endangerment and carrying a
weapon on school grounds for the latest
developments in this story and all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie